i'm really excited for our next guest
because she's a woman from louisiana
who just launched an incredible new
website
teaching american sign language to a
wider audience than ever and her mission
is to bring
the hearing and deaf communities closer
because it's very personal
for her please welcome tracy albert
hi crew hi tracy did you get my video by
the way
i did your video i was very very
impressed by it
okay good i i literally filmed it like
in the pitch black this morning
um and i saw your video okay so you did
this in honor of your parents will you
tell me about them
right so i grew up with two deaf parents
and i learned american sign language
first
so i'm also a baby sign language
instructor but i created the website
because i felt like they lacked
resources within their community
so i wanted to give a website for
everyone to learn and bridge that gap
between the hearing and deaf community
well i mean let's talk about the site
like how can people get started
so to get started we have basic asl
like the alphabet numbers colors
greetings and conversational starters
but they all start for 15 for students
um i mean i'm just gonna like show off
how this functions so basically i got
sort of a
mini tutorial um from tracy this morning
and so
hi my name is
d-r-e-w
of course i knew i told you on the video
i was like but hi
my oh god hi
my name is d-r-e-w
there we go that one was smoother and so
what's that
um finger spelling it's a little
impersonal so i created you your own
very own sign language name and so you
just go like this
and you do a d and it's true
oh i love that yeah
oh my god i had to like look in the
camera because i'm so enamored with the
beauty of
it can you tell me that the name um
feels seen it has a meaning behind it
will you please describe
it yes so my dad would always tell me
like he'll slap me little notes after
we'll have heart-to-heart conversations
and he'll be like thank you helping me
feel seen today and i thought that was a
really big lesson that everyone needs to
feel included in the math they have a
disability or not
i think that that story just really
moves me to no end
and i really love everything that you're
doing
and you even on your website are selling
these masks that have windows because so
much of
the communication is through lip reading
and facial expressions
right exactly well what you taught me
this morning like via video to video
at 5am i i was able to learn what now
makes me want to go out and start
expressing myself
so what we're going to do is we're going
to pay for every one of our vffs
to take one of your classes which will
in turn have the money go straight to
your organization
oh my god thank you and um
we just i thank you so much for teaching
me that i learned it so quickly
and it really compels me to want to keep
learning because the way that you taught
it
was so effective and fast so your
methodology is amazing
and i wish you the best of success and
um
thank you so much for coming on the show
to share your story thank you
for having me on the show thank you so
[Music]
much